hello everyone uh i'm michael goodman
i'm in the plant pathology department at
the university of kentucky
i want to start by thanking marilyn
rusin and tyler cecido and
lynn bernard uh for their very gracious
uh
invitation to present uh to you
and for all their help in uh getting
this talk
arranged uh technically so before i get
into this issue of how plant virology
can inform us
about emergence of zoonotic viruses such
as
sars co2 i want to give thanks to
this question is not mine it was a asked
by
a student group in brazil who invited me
to give a talk the
nephitch plant pathology group at the
university of dodge federal
lavros or ufla in brazil and
i thought this was a very intriguing
question and so um
i want to encourage graduate students
and undergraduates and
and postdocs to keep asking those sort
of out-of-the-box
questions because it gives us a time to
uh
process and think about innovative ideas
and then i want to go to this slide it's
a very stressful time in this pandemic
and we need a greater exposure to green
spaces to sort of
relax us a bit and that's the purpose of
this slide
a little bit and it's the hall of mosses
in olympic
national park but it has a greater
purpose
uh to show you that uh the humans are
are down at the very bottom
of the slide and that we are part of
this sort of
greater um greater picture
which are at least as big as these trees
and we tend to lose perspective
on that from time to time and so this
talk sort of addresses that type of
perspective
so one of the major points i i'd like to
make
in this talk is that when the
institutions that are tasked to detect
and control pandemic viral diseases
are operating effectively it appears as
if they're not doing anything at all
because there's hardly ever an outbreak
and when they
do they're contained and so outbreaks
become distant memories and there's a
perception that perhaps that they're
no longer outbreaks are no longer a
threat and and
so in 2019 in our
years leading up to that new animal
diseases
that can also infect humans were being
discovered at a rate of about
one every four months and
in october of 2019 the usaid
predict program which was tasked with
investigating
disease jumps from animals to humans was
was shut down and this sort of signaled
um what the response would be should
um a pandemic virus emerge
that was being uh surveyed here and so
with sort of that as background we have
to sort of uh consider
how the public perceives what an
outbreak uh
is and um it's sort of the hollywood
version of that is depicted here in this
movie and it kind of means
uh taking some of the greatest talent
that hollywood has
uh and giving them this really terrible
script
um and you know the the the
the job of hollywood is is to entertain
and so this is
an entertaining movie and a very
exciting movie it's not a great way
to learn uh virology and you wouldn't
want to take your
definition of outbreak from this movie
um so
something uh to reality and
in reality indeed is this wonderful
exhibit that the smithsonian
national museum of national uh natural
history
outbreak epidemics in a connected world
and this is really
phenomenal
exhibit and it will give you insight
into viruses like nipah and hendra
and hunter and and yellow fever and
small parts
zika and nile and west nile virus and
flu
and um so while while it is
so incredibly impressive um there's no
plant
virus included in this exhibit and i'm
going to tell you why
that should be the case and why that's
important
and one of the reasons is
that a lot of these viruses most people
won't even have contact with so it's
hard to make a personal connectivity to
this some of these viruses
are no longer generally generationally
connected and so people don't feel they
have a personal connection to it uh
and or outbreaks in general until
there is a more dramatic outbreak like
the emergence it says
cove ii uh in november of 2019
declared pandemic on march 11th of this
year
and interestingly declared pandemic
with just about three times the daily
case rate
of what's occurring in the united states
presently and so um this
concept of outbreak and emergence
is front and center in everybody's minds
today there's a very important
um point that needs to be made
here is that we've been here before
in human history and there are
two proven solutions to pandemics
one's vaccines we eradicated small pots
uh are well on our way to irradiating
polio measles hepatitis a and b
yellow fever mumps chickenpox human
papillomavirus
and then others and if not vaccines then
antiviral drugs
that have been so effective against hiv
and viruses like hepatitis c
but again this is these are all human
infecting
viruses and it's a very different
conversation that occurs
uh and people tend not to think about
uh plants in conversations about viruses
and i'm gonna try to convince you that
that really is
a problem that we have to solve um
and so why is that a problem so
uh we need to put that into a historical
context
before virology as a science existed so
let's go back to 1881.
charles darwin has just published his
last scientific book
and this is in 1881 this is the golden
age of german theory so
um louis pasteur is at his height and
he's discovering the vaccine
for anthrax carlos findlay is
is really thinking about
viral vectors yellow fever is not known
to be a virus at that time
but he's implicating insects in the
transmission of viruses
and yellow fever would go on to be the
first human virus isolated
c-sections and blood pressure
sphingomanometer is being invented and
so there's a
real revolution in germ theory and
medical
technologies so a year later in 1882
dmitry ivanovsky continuing on
experiments
initiated by adolf meyer showed that
in tobacco plants with mosaic
disease if you took sap from these
plants and passed them
through what's called a chamberlain
filter these
porcelain filters that can exclude
uh and filter out anything larger than
the size of a bacterium
uh to make this sterile solution c if
you pass this out through that
that the filtrates still retain
infectivity and again this is the golden
age of germ theory
robert [ __ ] is discovering the bacterium
responsible for tuberculosis
but here we have now a divergence of now
the demonstration of a sub-bacterial
infectious agent and this is really
the beginning of virology as a science
so
really important point uh to realize is
that virology
started with plant virology and that's a
very proud moment for our science
so if we fast forward to 2019
i can't do this so much this year but up
until this point
in 2019 let's say in to go to a grocery
store
and to find an unsuccessful uh
unsuspecting uh customer just trying to
pick out a great
cantaloupe or pineapple and to then
introduce yourself and say i'm from a
college of agriculture
i can help you with that decision if you
initiate such a conversation
what you'll find is that after a few
minutes people will start to say very
commonly
i didn't know plants get viruses and
um that's not in a general knowledge
in the public and that's a problem and
that's a problem
because 70 of our daily caloric
intake comes from seeds the
recommendations
in a healthy diet is that three quarters
of our diet
comes that should come directly from
plants as fruits vegetables grains
and then the meat and the dairy portions
of those
obviously require plant-based diets so
to not
know that all of this agricultural
productivity of
plants could be affected by viruses
will keep one from being cognizant
of what happens when plant viruses
emerge
and they can be absolutely devastating
as happened to my uncle warren in
jamaica
when i was a small child he was a papaya
farmer and was devastated by the
emergence
of papaya ring spot virus so 14 years
later
dennis gonzalez then at cornell
university
generates virus-resistant transgenic
papaya
that is practically immune to papaya
ring-spot virus and this recovers
the industry in uh
in hawaii but this is a not a technology
that spread due to uh
uh and my uncle was not able to reap the
benefit of that
because of anti-gmo sentiment but it's
an important fact
that scientists and virologists work
for the public good they are trying to
be there
to help and protect farmers and this is
our mission
and we have to tell these stories a very
important outcome of this though of
these transgenic papaya is that
28 years later after deployment
this remains some of the most robust
safest stable cost-effective sustainable
resistance
to a plant virus ever deployed and
we had the opportunity to deploy
antiviral crops
in a greater scale but we didn't for
example
in potato potato virus y pbx and potato
leaf roll virus
remain three of the major viral
pathogens on potato
even though we had engineered immunity
as early as 1995
in processing tomatoes being protected
by
a single gene sw5 against hospital
viruses this is now overcome
we could have stacked genetic uh and and
transgenic
antiviral strategies to help
lengthen the life of that gene and
protect against viruses
if you've ever been to brazil you know
how important maracuja or passion fruit
is uh for
for juices and we've had engineered
resistance
very effective against the major viral
pathogen of
passion fruit since 2005
and interestingly in sugar beet which is
50
of us sugar we've which
is mostly transgenic these days we've
never stacked in
to the transgenic herbicide resistance
the virus resistance
uh that causes uh rhizomania so
sort of lost opportunities in in
agriculture
um so with that as backgrounds
what we see in terms of plant virology
is revealed by the emergence of cyrus
cov2
copit19 it has revealed a widespread
lack of understanding of
fundamental principles of epidemiology
and in principles that really could have
been taught
uh with um with plant-based examples and
i want to give you a few of those
and so you might ask the question well
why don't people
think about viruses and discussions of
plants and and one of the reasons
i think is that well people think that
plants and animals and humans
are also very different that they don't
share these
sort of common disease causing agents
like viruses
so a really great question to ask at
this point is
just how different are we humans and
plants
and so we could play a little game uh
if you will and just try to answer a or
b
to this series of slides which is the
human
and which is the plant so hopefully you
got that
uh answered correctly which is the virus
infected human in which is the virus
infected plants
so you probably got that one right as
well
which is the human virus vector or
reservoir
and which is the plant virus vector and
so um it's here that some people may
have um
not quite sure um and then we get here
which is the virus-infected human cell
and which is the virus-infected plant
cell and it's really here
that most people with a really hard time
differentiating
plant from animal or human and i just
want to show you
that a is a human cell a
nucleus infected with influenza a virus
and in b is a plant that nucleus
infected
with sanchez yelling at virus and so um
here we have two viruses which is
negative strand rna viruses
they both replicate in nuclei of
infected cells their negative strand
rna viruses and so they're genetically
similar and
at this level they appear to be
very similar and so
i'll use examples quite a few examples
from the annual review of virology
chapter
and knowable magazine for the rest of
the talk and i just want to bring
attention to that
that once we get inside the cell it's
very difficult to distinguish plants
from
animals often for a number of phenomena
so whether or not we're talking about
genetic bottlenecks
in viral populations or how viruses
manipulate host membranes
or the conservation of cost factors
involved
in virus replication or recombination or
autophagy
very similar if not identical suites of
proteins and factors
in both plants humans and so um
that's a really important thing to
stress is that
in many of these uh phenomena we are
more similar than different
and and that idea becomes very important
if we then consider one of the major
goals
of the outbreak exhibit at the
smithsonian
that is by understanding how humans have
caused epidemics
in the past we can change our behavior
and now reduce the risks of epidemics in
the future
and so um the idea is that global
transport and travel
living close together changing the land
natural habitat and food production
all contribute to zoonotic virus
emergence
and i i want to stress one point
in that goal is that this idea that we
can change our behavior
and and so often human behavior
changes on a generational time scale and
this is why we have these legacies of
social and cultural
problems that are at least 400 years old
and so if we want to initiate change
faster
we have to have examples where
people are feel personally relevant and
connected
to the phenomena that we're trying to
explain to them and i will argue that
plant virology
really serves that purpose and so um
plant virology then becomes somewhat of
a model
system for zoonotic virus emergence and
um we've been here before in science
history
so the quantitative genetics invented
uh by gregor mendel using peas those
principles of inheritance are applicable
in a plant system and they're also
applicable in a human system as well and
so the the beauty of the model system
is that it's a simplified more tractable
system
that informs the more complex system
which is humans
and and so what i'd like to propose
is that we think about plant virology
for the rest of the talk
as a model system for zoonotic virus
emergence and so the hypothesis is that
if plant virology can inform human
virology
then the two should have in common
outbreak phenomena
sudden appearance spillover phenomena to
transfer from wild to domesticated areas
let's say common genetics similar type
of viruses
it should be in found in both cases it
should be a reliance on
vectors for spread and a maintenance
of viruses in the wild in reservoir
species
so if we're going to compare plant
viruses to zoonotic viruses and
find these commonalities then we need
a zoonotic reference and i'll use ebola
which first appeared in in 1976
and in the subsequent studies of this
virus what's become very important
is to know the reservoir species in you
know
in the wild and domestic um
reservoirs how does the virus get from
the reservoir
into other animals that are then either
consumed as food or have contact with
humans
certainly the disease ideology
epidemiology pathology
is essential in understanding spread and
transmission and
um and whether it's sexual transmission
or not
um and and so since 1976 there have been
these
24 uh ebola outbreaks um
all of which have been uh contained and
managed
and so we've learned a lot about how to
contain
and manage outbreak situations and sort
of a
summary of things that have to be done
in an outbreak situation you need very
rapid
deployments to uh to the outbreak
area of the professionals um capable of
dealing with such
situations uh testing uh screening
uh isolating infected patients in in
camps or field hospitals
quarantine uh people in in homes
or villages and diagnostics becomes
front line in managing the
um managing the outbreak
and so this is very similar in plant
viruses
virus indexing and diagnostic labs like
my collaborator antonia figuera at
buffalo
a really front line in tracking
the initial stages of outbreak and
following it through
and if we take all of that experience in
how to manage
outbreaks then what we see are these
curves that we've
all been talking about recently this
initial
increase in the number of cases
the start of the outbreak and its
establishment the so-called flattening
of the curve
and then a reduction in the number of
cases
to the point where then the outbreak is
declared
over and this requires a cross-border
sharing of information international
cooperation
and accurate diagnostic and reporting of
cases
so with ebola as a reference point
let's see if we can find implant
virology
those same parallel phenomena
and i'll i'll start with the
tostroviruses and gemini viruses
in plants so tasco viruses are extremely
important
so in this case here on vegetables um
and if we just look at the the virus and
example virus itself tomatoes spotted
wild virus it's a
envelope ambisense negative sense rna
single stranded rna virus
with a tripartite genome and
by its very genetics this plant virus
is similar to hantavirus and by a
broader extension of
the genetics of these viruses it's
similar to ebola and nipah
and these zoonotic viruses of of
humans not bats but thrifts
as a vector so this plant virus
has a trips as a vector
and if we look at a number of taskbar
viruses we have these
uh we find that they have a remarkable
broad
genetic diversity and so if we put this
sort of information together
and then ask well it's broad genetic
diversity and the
men the genome well is that bad in this
plant virus case
well it's bad for the exact same reason
that segmented genomes
a problem in influenza viruses right
and so if your viral
genome are like cards in a deck
you can shuffle the decks to make new
new hands new viruses
um new combinations of genetic material
and this happens both in influenza and
hospital viruses
which makes them very devastating
viruses in humans
and in agricultural as well
so uh another example uh the gemini
viruses these
viruses have circular uh single-stranded
dna genomes and we were worried about
the same thing
with gemini viruses as we are with
zoonotic
viruses um so one would go out and
collect
a number of isolates and sequence them
and find their genetic
uh relatedness to establish the
population structure we would ask
how many variants there are in the
population and
do the variance differ in variance
and if there's a particularly severe
variant
what is the probability that it may
spread or emerge in other
production areas so we will want to
quarantine
and use the same containment strategies
to prevent spread of severe strains
but not only do we need to know that for
the
viruses themselves we need to know it
for the vectors the population structure
the vectors so in this case
white flies uh and thrips and you can
just look at this
panel b and think if each one of those
white flies gets loaded with virus what
the
explosive spread of virus can be every
time the wind blows right
and so this is the problem that we have
to face
and and so with sort of this population
structure and genetics
we absolutely worry about emergence in
very much the same way
that you worry about zoonotic virus
emerges so
in the case of tomato chlorotic spot
virus
first found first emerged in brazil and
argentina in the 1980s
and then subsequently spread into the
caribbean basin in
in 2014 and this virus
can be maintained in wild reservoir
species
and it can go into a number of different
crops tomato pepper and tobacco shown
here
and so this is very similar in
in structure to having say a bat
reservoir
and then that virus is capable of going
into chimpanzees
humans and macaques say like ebola would
so the parallels are the same
so the other examples in cassava
diseases
and so like zoonotic viruses plant
viruses
show this phenomenon of
being discovered and characterized but
really remaining quiescent for a very
long period of time
so cassava brown street virus was first
detected in 1936 but
population density planting density
germplasm
being used changing in climatic and
environmental factors all contribute
to emergence and so there's explosive
spread
of cassava brown streak starting about
2004.
for those of you not familiar with
cassava it's one of the most
important food sources in the world to
about a billion and a half people
this is a an example here in brazil and
it's fried for manchester
um as you might encounter it but it's
subsistence food
to um hundreds of millions of people
and it is plagued by two major viral
diseases
brown streak and and mosaic and so
the mosaic is another one of these
gemini viruses
with these circular dna genomes and
cassava brown street virus is a
hypamovirus
which like sars cove ii is basically
a giant messenger rna that's
encapsulated that is translated to make
a polyprotein and then proteolytically
processed so you could teach uh very
effectively
the genetics of starscope to like
viruses
in a plant-based system hands-on
and just like virus emergence
for zoonotic viruses we worry about the
very same thing for these cassava
viruses so we want to know
where do both viruses occur and can you
have co-infections
what are the areas where you only have
one virus
and not the other and where are areas
where cassava is planted on a large
scale where these viruses don't
exist and what quarantine and monitoring
systems can we put in place
to protect those crops in those areas
and so this is really
the goals of things like the cassava
action project which are using
uh on farm diagnostics using
nanopore next generation sequencing
technologies to business diagnosis
and then projects like the
virus-resistant cassava for
africa which has developed transgenic
very effective transgenic
anti-viral plants uh resistant to to
cassava brown streak
and so our initial uh perception of gmos
have to be
re-evaluated because really this is um
frontline technology in comparing these
really
important uh viruses so the next
um example i want to get into is
addresses this idea of co-infections
there's a lot of discussions now about
um what corporate 19 is going to be
like during flu season so what happens
when influenza virus
shows up and in terms of co-infections
plant viral virology has a lot to say so
the example here
is maize lethal necrosis or mln
and it addresses this idea of
synergistic viral diseases
so this viral synergy comes
from having this one virus mesh
chloratic
model virus which by itself is not
particularly
devastating in plants and then we have
these other
num of podia viruses themselves that
make polyproteins
and any number of these are
can cause disease but usually not to a
great extent
but in a co-infection there's a
synergistic uh
amplification of the disease severity
which is can be catastrophic and so
to think about synergistic interactions
we can use plant-based examples and this
mln follows the same sort of
emergence phenomena that you would see
uh let's say
uh with stars coke ii or herbal this
first
appearance in 1974 in peru and then
subsequent uh pandemic virus over
subsequent
uh years and so uh the world
being what it is population density and
urbanization
and global travel we really have to
know uh with increasing some uh
sophistication
where uh all viruses are at all times
certainly the ones that cause diseases
are potential for disease
in humans and plants and so this idea
and and um of spill over and spill back
from wild reservoirs into domestic um or
inhabited areas
is a is a really big problem and uh in
both plant virology and zoonosis right
and so preventing the next epidemic
really requires
knowing what's out there in increasing
sophistication
and that means being able to survey
and collect on broad scales we have
developed
diagnostic tools to characterize these
novel viruses
um and generate databases that are
internationally accessible
so this data can be shared to uh
consider
uh outbreak potential um and then sort
of
if we drive this uh to its uh sort of
the maximum uh we'd like to know
every virus in every host certainly in
terms of the ones that cause
diseases in in humans and plants and
increasingly we can do this with greater
and greater sophistication
and so this these just happen to be
gemini viruses in brazilian
non-cultivated plants and credit to
murillo zubini
at ufb in vissosa
brazil because we need to know this
information because there will always be
another
outbreak and that means we need to
really train
the next generation of diagnosticians
because they are
really the front lines against uh
outbreaks
and um so um colleagues here selection
of back in florida
and nicole gotcha and university of
kentucky are
really important in this and so
um what i'm trying to convince you
uh in this talk um is that
the factors that drive zoonotic
emergence
also drive plant virus emergency mixed
infections
genetic variability adaption adaptation
to host
habitat conversion reservoirs and
cultural practices
they're really parallel systems and so
with the examples i've provided i
hope i've convinced you or stimulated to
think
more about that indeed plant virology
can
inform human virology and zoonotic
outbreak
because it has this these outbreak
phenomena
spillover phenomena common genetics of
the viruses
reliance on vectors and um
reservoir species but more important
uh or for going forward
in all of this is we spend a lot of time
talking about how different things are
and there needs to be a greater
conversation
about how things are more alike than
difference at all levels of conversation
we can start that with viruses
um particularly because it's very
difficult to distinguish
a plant from animal within within the
cell so we can
drive these comparisons of similarity
more than differences and and so um the
other thing revealed by cobit 19 at
least to me
is that more people need to know about
plant virus emergence
and so it was really an honor to be
invited
to co-edit um viruses special issue
that'll be coming out
on plant virus emergence and i'm doing
this in partnership with jean marie
versio
at tamil it's really phenomenal a
collection of manuscripts being
submitted
and i look forward to having that shared
with you
so in addition to using
plant virology as a model system covet
19 is revealed
other aspects of our society that we
really need to address
if you were an educator instructor
doing outreach we really have to get
a greater understanding of the
scientific methods so
in my science outreach
website i have a exercise that uses
trees as a model system to demonstrate
the scientific method i'd be happy to
share that
with anyone and encourage you to use it
it's a very user-friendly
interactive procedure we need to tell
more stories
about how scientists and virologists are
human
and they work in the greater good uh and
they don't
um uh operate in nefarious ways
uh they truly are human working for uh
the greater good
um we if we consider
whether or not a virus is alive it gives
us a great
uh thought experiment for trying to
define
what is living and if you can do it
relevant to a conversation about whether
or not
a virus is alive is a really wonderful
conversation
to be had and it makes us
increase or reduce our pettiness and
increase
and show that we have to have an
absolute need for empathy
and and thinking that there are things
beyond ourselves
that are part of this greater good give
us this
2020 vision if you will going forward
in a post covet 19 world that has
greater empathy
and so these are all um at the green
orange cafe
and finally given that vaccine
candidates
are in various stages of clinical trials
and then we will get one
we need uh political leadership um
when these uh are available
uh to lead the way in the benefit of
this vaccine technology and if not
political leadership
then then uh pop color culture icons
like elvis presley who took the salt
vaccine in 1956
to get people encouraged uh because
if we do that then soon enough
we will have sars cove ii uh on one or
both of these lists as the way to
overcome
uh solutions to pandemics so with that
i thank you for your attention i want to
thank
many of the authors and contributors and
editorial staff at
uh annual review of virology been
phenomenal team
to work with colleagues in brazil
ufla and ufv and
the college of agriculture food and
environment at the university of
kentucky
a great colleagues that have
um many conversations
contributing to this talk the student
group message uh
at ufla and um some of these
more sociology science meets the
crossroads
of society essays are on my
website and blog at the green orange
cafe so thank you very much
for your attention and i look forward to
answering any questions
you care to email and i'll be happy to
follow up
with this discussions